earlier we learned about styles and how
you can apply them to an individual view
if you want to apply it to all the views
in an activity or application you can do
it by specifying a theme attribute on
the activity or application tag in the
Android manifest now we style the action
bar to look like these visual mocks for
the main and detail activity the
settings activity is a special case
because it extends from the preference
activity class instead of the action bar
activity so that's going to be done in
the next section for both cases here we
want the background color to be this
blue hex color we notice that the detail
activity only shows the title no app
icon and this button is to go up to the
parent activity if you see visual mocks
that have the app icon or a different UP
button they are outdated with material
design this is our new look on the other
hand the main activity shows the logo
it's a different attribute than the app
icon and this was provided in an asset
drop earlier in the lesson and it's
called icy underscore logo because of
these differences we need to separate
themes we use app theme for the detail
activity and forecast theme for the main
activity in material design you can
choose several app colors and specify
them in your theme to colorize certain
UI components that are controlled by the
framework for example the framework will
use color primary as the background of
your action bar or your tool bar the
framework will also use color primary
dark as the status bar color to
customize our app theme go to the Styles
file in the values folder our app theme
inherits from the system theme for a
light app because we have a light
content area with a dark action bar we
specify color primary to be this
sunshine blue color and this will be
displayed in the action bar also known
as app bar and then we set the color
primary dark to be this darker color
this is going to be shown in the status
bar and typically the status bar is a
darker color than the app bar both of
these colors are defined in the color's
XML file as seen here then for the main
activity we create a forecast theme we
inherit from the app theme in case
there's more attributes that we want to
add here and then we'll inherit them for
free how
we do over I the action bar style this
is so that we can set the logo to point
to this drawable file and also change
the display options so that the logo
does appear for more information on the
action bar display options you can see
the list here if you run the app now
there's a shadow below the action bar
that is default behavior however
according to our visual designs we want
the action bar and the today item with a
blue background to be on the same plain
meaning we don't want one to cast a
shadow over the other as a result we set
the action bar elevation to be zero if
it's in one pane mode if it's in two
pane mode then the today item does not
have a special background and it's fine
if the action bar casts a shadow go
ahead and make these changes now using
the gists provided